[Musique]
cette prison le pénitencier saint-pierre
à la passe klaus altmann libéré sous
caution a franchi cette porte pour une
destination inconnue protégée par la
police il se cache quelque part en
bolivie ou ailleurs trois fois déjà la
france avait demandé l'extradition de
klaus barbie alias altman condamné à
mort par contumace pour cette ordure à
la gestapo de lyon
1945 barbie s'enfuit vers l'allemagne
vera oxbow en 1948 on le retrouve à
munich
la même année au mois d'août un policier
français l'interrogent comme simple
témoin barbie est protégé par les
services secrets américains première
demande d'extradition
on le signale à stuttgart à kent puis à
gênes en italie
1950 par l'intermédiaire de la croix
rouge de genève barbie se procure un
titre de transport pour la bolivie
il a changé de nom après my hair wright
wilms nicolas hébergés il adopte une
nouvelle identité
altman 1951 klaus altmann est à la passe
six ans plus tard sous cette fausse
identité il se naturalisent bolivia
passeport officiel numéro 5 buts 8 7 1
en février dernier il faisait escale à
paris il s'en est vanté mais les
autorités françaises ont aujourd'hui des
preuves formelles barbie et altman le
fond cas aujourd'hui
le président hugo banzer étudie la
lettre que lui a personnellement adressé
le président pompidou
souvenez vous mardi 8 février à 24
heures sur l'a 2 en direct quatre
résistants interrogé torturé ou déportés
par barbie était confronté avec altman
[Musique]
les phases à la gestapo budget ce
n'était pas à la gestapo non fille de la
reine
je ne m'étais pas à la distance je suis
pas un assassin
je ne suis pas un assassin
je n'ai jamais torturé selon vous
souvenir personnel qui je le rappelle
date de près de trente ans maintenant
pensez vous que klaus altmann puisse
être klaus barbie
madame lallange j'ai été je vais 13 ans
en présence souviens très bien de regard
pour moi ya pas de problème
l'alluré générale et surtout la la façon
de regarder cet homme me rappelle
étrangement ce bar big j'ai connu plus
tard ya 30 ans honnêtement je ne peux
pas affirmer que je le reconnais
cependant mes réticences de ces
dernières semaines ça me nuit j'ai
retrouvé chez cet homme
la bouche les lèvres quelques formes de
quelques expressions du visage la forme
générale du visage la façon de baisser
les yeux de les relever rapidement de
tourner la tête et j'ai éprouvé en
regardant ces images un petit peu là
la crainte l'appréhension que j'avais en
regardant barbie la base février 1972
[Musique]
une femme une jeune allemande
madame klarsfeld à relancer la chasse
contre klaus barbie jusqu'en bolivie
pourquoi je suis toujours dans toutes
mes actions la chasse des crimes nazis
et les protestations contre
l'antisémitisme dans pires j'essaie
toujours de toutes ces actions steria
bri et moralement le peuple allemand
parce que je suis j'ai une très forte ce
sentiment national allemande et suppose
âge ma pause fortement à ces gens comme
barbie qui ont sali le nom de
l'allemagne
je suis venu ici avec les documents que
j'ai reçu du procureur de munich
d'ailleurs quelques jours avant mon
départ et je suis venu pour les montrer
aux autorités boliviennes pour qu'ils
puissent rendre compte et composites a
demandé barbie sont bien la même
personne une niche parution nous attend
jan nygren disons de lens ou bien sûr la
sdat sur programmes contiennent les
dates de naissance des enfants de
classes hartmann et de klaus barbie et
selon les recherches de la police il ya
une coïncidence que les enfants
d'harmony gold avant de klaus barbie
portent les prénoms
ils sont mais aînés et aux mêmes dates
et qu'ils défendent barbie fête
[Musique]
vous avez déclaré récemment de klaus
altmann
à votre avis est bien klaus barbie
l'ancien chef de la gestapo de lyon
comment êtes vous parvenus à cette
conclusion ils allaient nous avons
retrouvé des photographies de klaus
barbie du temps où il était à la gestapo
nous sommes ensuite procuré deux
nouvelles photos de claude piquemal en
bolivie nous ont fait faire une
expertise anthropométriques quand
l'université de munich
cette expertise permet de conclure que
klaus barbie
mais klaus altmann selon la plus grande
vraisemblance sont identiques innus est
ce que vous êtes catégorie
je suis convaincue qu'il ne peut y avoir
aucun doute pour le procureur rudolf le
dossier est accablant pour le professeur
égale maillard aussi nous n'avons pu
travailler que sur des photographies les
seuls éléments à notre disposition nous
avons cependant déterminé de nombreux
signes particuliers notamment dans les
régions du nez de l'oreille de la bouche
des yeux est ici en haut des sourcils
ce sont des détails que l'on peut
observer sans équivoque sur les deux
photographies et qui sont totalement
identique
les détails sont si nombreux l'hypothèse
d'un hasard avec une telle ressemblance
entre les deux hommes est si mince que
nous pouvons dire souffle les deux
hommes reproduit sur ces photographies
sont avec le maximum de ressemblance
identique
je dois ajouter ceci pour aucun des
détails qu'il m'a été permis d'observer
je n'ai trouvé de contradictions ou de
différences entre les deux séries de
photographies de ce sous sol du film de
sundance et allemagne
je veux montrer des photographies de
barbie qui avait été prise au moment de
la guerre je les présente à monsieur
altman pour voir s'il lui reconnaît
quand isabelle aux écossais regardez
bien
klaus altmann vient apposer ses
empreintes sur les photos de barbie avec
le film que je viens de voir ce qui est
très intéressant c'est de localiser la
trace laissée par altman et qui semblait
un pouce et se trouvait d'ailleurs dans
cette zone là il semble qu'il y en ait
une ici qui est obligé d'être achevée à
la poudre d'aluminium
mais celle-là est impeccable
et ce qui serait maintenant très
intéressant pour nous ce serait d'avoir
les empreintes de barbie pour pouvoir
les comparer à cette photographie et de
la avoir la preuve irréfutable si c'est
lui ou pas lui une empreinte suffit
qu'elle a condamné un homme oui à partir
du moment où vous avez fait l expertise
et que vous possédez un nombre de points
un moloch caractéristiques et une seule
on prend une seule un poussin doigt un
fragment de droit suffisent
et quel est le rapport de chances pour
que deux empreintes soient semblables
chez deux individus eu dix experts vous
diront qu'il ya une chance sur je crois
que c'est 10 milliards d'empreintes
une autre expérience nous avons réussi à
nous procurer en bolivie deux signatures
d'altman un des principaux experts
devant les tribunaux les compare à
celles de barbie écrite voici 29 ans ces
deux documents ont la particularité
d'être tous les deux de février le de 43
l'autre de 72 quand on les examine celui
de gauche et celui de droite on trouve
cependant des parentés c'est assez
curieux malgré la déformation certaine
et volontaire de la signature de 72 de
klaus altmann
il y a la même façon d'aborder la
signature cette même ondulations légère
la finale de barbe et se termine par un
petit ergo léger est un point très
décalé et d'une façon inexplicable la
finale de claus se termine par le même
petit ergo léger et par un point très
décalé nous allons passer de ses
origines ou à des diapositives que j'ai
fait faire pouvoir mieux comprendre la
question oui ici d'abord cette barre
qu'il précède la signature de barbie et
puis nous avons deuxièmement cette
arcade de la base la signature qui est
curieuse et dans cette signature qui
apparaît ici de klaus nous allons le
même départ ondulant et aussi la même
finale crocheté avec ce petit point on
peut pas négliger le rapprochement très
important qui existe entre cette
première signature et ses deuxièmes
gignac
nous nous faisons ça comment je ne vais
pas à la gestapo quitus ce n'était pas à
la gestapo
lyon les centaines d'arrestations de
tortures de déportation un résistant
maurice boudé se souvient se regarde
j'ai eu en face de moi presque pendant
deux mois j'ai été arrêté à lyon
fourvière le 9 juillet 1943 par lui même
et le soir même j'ai été transféré à la
centrale de la gestapo lyonnaise qui se
tenait à cette époque là à l'école du
service de santé militaire avenue
berthelot et là j'ai commencé à faire sa
connaissance
il avait un regard d'acier cruel audiard
épouvantable quand on l'a vu une fois on
ne pouvait pas l'oublier des deux hommes
qui vous casser la figure sans aucun
scrupule qui voulait jouer encore les
jeunes clubman qui voulait être élégant
ne pas s'abîmer les manchettes quand ils
vous dans le sang jaillit c'est notre
corps parce qu'ils vous avez tellement
tapé dessus
lorsqu'on avait tourné de l'oeil vous
ranimer à coups de pied dans les
endroits les plus sensibles du corps
ailleurs commencé mais c'était un une
véritable joie sadique de vous de vous
torturer et ça a duré deux mois
les premiers interrogatoires c'était
tous les jours d'un jour sur l'autre
c'était une appréhension de plus en plus
grande
mais après les interrogatoires se sont
espacés à peu près deux fois par semaine
pourquoi parce que quand on vous ramener
dans la prison de montluc dans une
cellule sur une civière le lendemain on
était incapable de répondre on était
encore dans les vapes on ne savait plus
ce qu'on disait on ne pouvait plus
réalisé alors il fallait le temps
minimum physiologiques de récupération
et après ça recommence
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas de jean moulin est mort il
y en a des quantités car sont morts dont
on ne parle pas
m
on
[Musique]
j'habite à saint vaast civisme et ben d
espagne objectivement laquelle je
présente lens altran la photo de jean
moulin
je lui demandais ce que leurs tenues de
niche mais c'est manning qui se désister
fautif il ya jeunesse gmt ce lundi 19 à
l'isie stand up
dignitaires sophie lichten les mavs et
ce désert l'artisanat sion la limmat
française multiplie ses cheveux foncés
je ne suis pas un assassin
je ne suis pas seulement sa salle je
n'ai jamais torturé ce n'est jamais
sortir et je ne suis jamais allé à à la
gestapo de lyon
je ne suis jamais allé à la gestapo de
lyon puis jamais cédé à la case départ
de lyon je ne connais pas jean moulin je
ne connais pas ces photos sont
exclusives elles ont été prises en
allemagne en 1948
barbie était déjà protégée par les
services secrets alliez vous voyez ici
cette irrégularité des zones de la ligne
supérieure des sources et il est
possible qu'elles correspondent à ce que
nous voyons ici au dessus de l'oeil
gauche de sujets deviennent des sujets
âgés
ce peut être une forme de souris qu'on
retrouve sur le des photos finalement il
ya un point de ressemblance semble-t-il
ce que l'antenne x16 apparaît nettement
bien sûr et vous voyez vous le défi est
précis semble-t-il et sur cette photo on
a l'impression qu'il ya aussi des
formations bien que ce ne soit pas aussi
évident que sur la première fois sous la
photo de la magie une autre épreuve dite
de galles tonnes qui consiste à
superposer un négatif de la photo de
barbie en 1948 et un négatif de sel
d'altman en 1972 permettrait peut-être à
des spécialistes de l'anthropométrie de
trouver une preuve de la similitude de
certaines formes entre les deux hommes à
genève au siège de la croix rouge
athmane a laissé une photo ses
empreintes et sa signature dans les
étages elle est par une organisation
caritative
il s'est adressé à nous pour avoir un
titre de voyage d'autre part je dois
vous dire que pour obtenir un titre de
voyage du cicr il faut également avoir
un visa d'entrée dans le pays où le
réfugié désirent se rendre et
naturellement un visa de sortie du pays
dans lequel à ce moment là le réfugié
or la libye avait avait donné un visa
d'entrée elle était donc d'accord
d'accueillir iceman et l'autre par
l'italienne naturellement d'accord de le
laisser partir
sur cent cinquante mille titres de
voyages délivrés c'est fort possible
peut-être que parmi eux il ya quelques
criminels de guerre mais il faut
considérer le nombre de vies humaines
qui ont été sauvées par ces titres et je
crois qu'ils les gardent toute leur
valeur
c'est le cas du cheval aussi quelques
titres de voyage un titre de voyage
stylisme
russie compte c'est ici dans le quartier
de soho procacci derrière de hauts murs
que klaus altmann s'était réfugié depuis
sa fuite du pérou propice pour le
cerveau le policier dit indien sur cet
entretien n'a pas été facilitée par la
police bolivienne
mais le sourire d'altman en dit long
c'est qu'il faut faire olivia nicher
polizei chipset et bavard
[Musique]
ici le souvenir du nazisme n'est plus le
même qu'en europe on est à dix mille
kilomètres des champs de bataille
ce cimetière est exclusivement réservé
aux allemands 178 tombe un symbole dans
la même rue côte à côte
l'ambassade de france l'ambassade
d'allemagne et le ministère de
l'intérieur où l'on examine la dernière
demande d'extradition
cette demande doit être examinée par les
organismes bolivien compétents et notre
pays est régi par ses propres lois
il respecte et faire respecter les
traités et les accords internationaux
[Musique]
au milieu albane vous avez monsieur ben
oui je ne sais pas vous avez la
conscience tranquille de la semaine donc
un ministre islamiste euros soit un prix
elle a un sauteur et ce n'était pas à la
gestapo
je ne suis pas ce n'est pas sale je n'ai
jamais porté
[Musique]